la tempête souffle sur tout l'ouest de
la france des vents de 180 km/heure des
creux de plus de 10 mètres mais
heureusement pas trop de dégâts pour
l'instant le point complet dans ce
journal avec nos envoyés spéciaux
les premiers témoignages sur la tuerie
qui aurait fait 402 morts dans l'ouest
algérien sont diffusées par la
télévision nationale fait rarissime les
rangs condamne ces attentats la crise
avec israël en israël avec la démission
du ministre des affaires étrangères
david levy l'ennemi intime de benyamin
nétanyahou dispose encore de 48 heures
pour faire machine arrière
le paris dakar première étape africaine
et d'entrée de jeu le grand favori dans
la catégorie motos vétéran de seine se
portent aux premières places et puis mc
solaar le poète du rap le magicien des
mots il sera notre invité dans ce
journal avant sa rentrée au zénith à
paris le 9 janvier madame monsieur
bonsoir toute la façade ouest de la
france est en prise à des vents violents
pour l'instant les dégâts ne sont pas
trop importants mais les vents
atteignent par endroits 180 km/heure
force 11 comme disent les marins et la
mer s'est creusé avec des vagues de plus
de 10 mètres voyons d'abord ce qu'il en
est dans le finistère à la pointe de la
bretagne avec arnaud goûter et luc
bachofen
quelques milles au large des côtes
brestoise et déjà les vagues géantes
déferlent dans un océan blanc démonter
un fort coefficient de marée
le vent qui souffle à plus de 130
kilomètres heure et c'est le spectacle
de ces immenses prochainement
la tempête c'est également cela les
orages de grêle et des bourrasques à
plus de 170 km heure les pompiers du
finistère ont effectué plus de 300
interventions
la plus impressionnante dans cet
immeuble à concarneau
la cheminée tomber défonçant la toiture
et les trois étages il y avait cinq
personnes à l'intérieur aucun blessé
amir personne qui était dans son livre
le troisième étage dans la partie
concernée par l'effondrement qui
uniquement interne à l'établissement et
donc elle s'est retrouvée au niveau du
premier étage dans beaucoup de chance
demain
oh non non on est encore toujours plus
conforme au service prévisions de météo
france
on suit de très près l'évolution de la
dépression la nuit s'annonce difficile
avec des vents violents et un deuxième
front harry pas de quoi rassurer les
marins pêcheurs depuis mardi est la
première tempête toute sortie en mer
reste impossible sauf pour quelques gros
navire est certes un gros chalutiers qui
sont en mer lâché pince ceux qui vont
rentrer la risée rose auront sûrement
de la très grosse mer et y en a un qui
est rentré hier chevalier
ils disaient qu'ils avaient tous les
petits chalutiers reste sagement alignés
derrière la digue le vent atteint
parfois fort ce 11 % 11 c'est tout
simplement un cran en dessous de l'oural
un peu plus au sud d'olivier sioux et
gabriel camilla se trouve sur la
presqu'île de quiberon balayer l'oci par
les vents le sémaphore de l'île de groix
dans le morbihan enregistré dès ce matin
des rafales de 180 km/heure la pointe du
perche ans est l'un des hauts lieux
touristiques de la presqu'île de
quiberon
même lorsque le vent souffle à 150 km
les élus de la presqu'île ont pris des
arrêtés interdisant de s'y promener à
pied ce week end
des arrêtés qui apparemment n'ont pas
dissuadé grand monde d'aller vérifier au
plus près des vagues bien sûr si les
creux font effectivement dit m
avec sa part dit de venir ici on aurait
attendu que ce n'est pas prudent mais un
père aimant et l'expérience
une attitude qui a le don d'exaspérer le
maire de saint pierre quiberon
même s'il reconnaît avoir du mal à faire
appliquer son propre arrêté malgré les
patrouilles et les procès verbaux peut
pas mettre un gendarme
tous les dix mètres sur la côte sauvage
c'est pas possible l'effectif est
beaucoup trop restreint d'ailleurs mais
bon on a fait quelques patrouilles bon
le temps de la patrouille on arrive à
les faire revenir aux voitures mais on
est à peine parti que ça recommence
et pourtant le danger était bien réel
cet après midi à quiberon pendant que
les visiteurs influer vers la côte
sauvage comme aux plus beaux jours de
l'été un arbre tombé sur la route qui
traverse toute la presqu'île
par chance il n'y avait pas de voiture
en 200 au total les pompiers quiberon
fait une vingtaine d'interventions dans
l'après midi
pas trop de dégâts dans l'ensemble
essentiellement des arbres abattus des
ardoises arraché les toits depuis le
coup de vent de vendredi expliquent les
pompiers eux-mêmes
presque tous ceux qui devaient tomber
était déjà par terre
ici au moins la tempête de ce week end
aura surtout fourni de belles images et
quelques sensations fortes
alors nous allons retourner voir arnaud
boutet qui se trouve à brest dans toute
la région les trains ont subi des
retards en raison des avaries provoquées
par les tempêtes sur les lignes
électriques
et la situation n'est pas meilleure
arnaud pour les habite torrent baizil à
800 ou à belle île
les liaisons lasson sont interrompues et
le continent oui derrière moi il ya des
bateaux de pêche qui restent sur le quai
qui ne peuvent sortir du port un peu
plus loin il ya des navires des navettes
qui devait rejoindre quelques îles au
large de la bretagne alors ce soir l'île
de groix d'ouessant de molène bélisle
reste complètement impossible d'accès il
n'y a pas de bateau il n'ya pas d'avion
les habitants et plusieurs centaines de
touristes ne peuvent rejoindre le
continent
la tempête qui sévit aujourd'hui qui
sévit ce soir encore se déplace
progressivement vers le nord elle
devrait atteindre l'angleterre et les
secouristes n'ont qu'un seul message à
faire passer aux bretons d'éviter tout
simplement de sortir de chez eux ce soir
d'éviter de prendre la route tout
simplement merci arnaud alors vous le
disiez c'est bien sur l'ensemble de
l'europe qui est concerné par cette
tempête qui a déjà fait deux morts en
belgique et en allemagne qui a fait un
autre mort au large de l'irlande et dans
l'atlantique c'est un chalutier espagnol
qui a dû être secouru par les
garde-côtes anglais bien sûr les
liaisons entre la france et l'angleterre
sont largement perturbé alban nicosie
une heure de retard pour les ferries de
cette compagnie la seule qui assure
encore en fin d'après-midi la traversée
france angleterre
en fait c'est toute la façade nord ouest
de l'europe qui a vécu un dimanche agité
le littoral nord de la france où de
nombreux promeneurs ont affronté les
rafales un vent qui rend toute
navigation particulièrement périlleuse
parfois comme en loire atlantique des
phénomènes d'une extrême violence frappe
brutalement ce lotissement de saint
nazaire a été traversé par une mini
tornade
trois personnes ont été blessées quinze
maisons endommagées le problème c'est
qu'on a beaucoup d'interventions à la
fois et sur un grand secteur
toutefois nous devons mobiliser déjà des
hommes hier en puisque le préavis
tempête est déjà pas mal en ces demandes
vont mobiliser du potentiel et demandait
des centres de secours en renfort en
normandie
hier soir un échafaudage de 140 tonnes
s'est effondrée comme un château de
cartes
emportant avec lui le clocher de
l'église de la feuillie il n'y a pas de
blessé mais une cinquantaine d'habitants
a été évacuées de leurs logements par
mesure de précaution cet après-midi la
tempête et une houle assez fortes ont
déferlé sur le cotentin où une rafale à
156 km heure a été enregistré au
sémaphore de la presqu'île ici toute
navigation a été suspendue
même image sur la côte picarde la
commune de mers-les-bains vu déferler
des vagues de plusieurs mètres dans les
rues depuis vendredi les pompiers ont
multiplié les interventions mais là
aussi aucune victime n'est à déplorer
situation plus délicate enfin sur les
îles britanniques des pluies diluviennes
ont noyé une partie du sud de
l'angleterre et du pays de galles
cinquante mille personnes sont à l'heure
actuelle privées d'électricité et les
rivières ont atteint leur cote d' alerte
et les mauvaises conditions météo la
pluie le vent rendent les retours de
vacances particulièrement délicat comme
on le voit sur ces images de l'autoroute
a6 que nous envoie à vider guyot en
revanche rien n'indique pour l'instant
que le mauvais temps soit à l'origine du
carambolage qui s'est produit sur
l'autoroute a10 près de saint denis sur
loire une quinzaine de voitures ont été
endommagées et 15 personnes légèrement
blessées
sur cette même autoroute a10 au péage de
châtellerault une quarantaine de
chômeurs ont organisé une opération
péage gratuit
malgré l appel de martine aubry hier
soir les chômeurs poursuivre leur
mouvement une douzaine de caisses
assedic sont toujours occupés et la
semaine qui vient s'annonce décisive
c'est en effet mercredi que doit se
réunir le conseil d'administration de
l'unedic et les chômeurs ont l'intention
d'en faire le point d'orgue de leur
action reportage à marseille de jacques
cardoze et vincent des ombres une
troisième semaine de conflit s'achève
une autre va commencer et pas question
de lâcher prise malgré les menaces
d'évacuation les chômeurs des bouches du
rhône entendent poursuivre l'occupation
de locaux des assedic
même si pour martine aubry plus rien ne
justifie que ces actions perdure dans
l'illégalité
on partira des assedic parce qu'on sera
obligé de partir des a cédé mais il est
prévu qu'on aille en d'autres endroits
mais la lutte ne s'arrêtera pas pour
autant ne s'est toutefois pas pour
autant au contraire elle n'a fait que
l'amplifier ce qui est dommage pour elle
parce que là nous sommes vraiment tous
tous en colère en colère et déçu par les
déclarations du ministre du travail r
qualifier ici l'insuffisante est le
crois que si on se bat pour une prime
c'est une revendication saugrenue pour
les ja qui devrait demander d'abord du
travail or le problème c'est que je
demande c'est d'abord parce qu'on avait
imaginé un peu pendant lève le 13e mois
ou cheminot je sais pas qui moi il
serait tout à la rue ils auraient réseau
dans la semaine les partenaires sociaux
doivent discuter du financement de
l'allocation de formation reclassement
et des indemnités chômage ce qui retient
d'ores et déjà l'attention des chômeurs
moi je dis haut et fort depuis le début
que tous les trois mois tous les
semaines 2 jours on nous enlève 17 pour
ça on est en a eu des donc allocation
unique dégressive ce que ce qui veut
dire qu'on devrait aller voir nos
propriétaires leur demander de nous
décemment nos loyers de 10 7%
l'edf pour aller les voir leur demande
et 17 pour ça les sans emplois se
prépare à de nouvelles actions comme
celle de ce soir à marseille et envisage
de gêner la tenue du conseil
d'administration de l'unedic qui se
tient mercredi car de l'issue de cette
réunion dépend l'avenir de leur
mouvement et invité de l'émission de
michèle cotta polémique ce midi sur
france 2 alain madelin a jugé légitime
la révolte des chômeurs je pense que
c'est une révolte l'egypte je mesure
bien évidemment une petite manipulation
pour les plus que peut y avoir derrière
de tels comités mais il est vrai que
nous avons là l'illustration d'un thème
à nouveau qui m'est cher celui de la
déchirure sociale celui de cette misère
qui est en train de ronger la société
française de ces familles entières de
ces jeunes qui se retrouvent sans espoir
trop vieux pour avoir un travail trop
jeune pas d'expérience pour prétendre
aussi à un emploi comment ne pas
rapprocher ces mouvements de chômeurs de
l'autre côté je crois si tu es le
mondial de football quand vous voyons
une grève dans les transports parisiens
parce que l'on prévoit qu'il y aura trop
de monde dans les transports au moment
du mondial de football alors on sait gré
mais décidément il ya deux poids deux
mesures dans ce pays
ils y allaient politiquement faibles et
notamment les chauffeurs je trouve
qu'ils ont raison de redouter une
mauvaise nouvelle pour les fumeurs c'est
demain qu'augmente le prix des
cigarettes une hausse moyenne de 3 7 %
que les fabricants ne répercuteront pas
tous de la même façon à l'étranger
maintenant l'afflux de réfugiés kurdes
continue d'agiter les principales
capitales européennes selon les
autorités allemandes dix mille kurdes se
préparerait à quitter la turquie pour
l'italie ce que démentent ankara tout en
regrettant que rome ait décidé
d'accorder l'asile politique aux
réfugiés kurdes le président du conseil
italien lui en appelle à une coopération
européenne
en attendant les réfugiés sont maintenus
dans des camps en italie comme ont pu
constaté philippe rochot et jacques
gérard à brindisi
ils ont échoué ici dans le petit port de
sainte foca sur la côte adriatique comme
salim et ils ne savent plus comment
sortir de là les 380 réfugiés kurdes du
navire la comète ont débarqué là le 1er
janvier les deux tiers viennent d'irak
les autres de turquie et il raconte que
quand tu es kurdes on veut couper la
tête
ils viennent chercher les gens chez eux
avec le pistolet sur la tempe et il les
menace céline lui explique que la police
et l'armée sont venus l'arrêter chez lui
et qui l'ont accusé de faire partie du
pkk le parti communiste du kurdistan les
réfugiés kurdes n'ont pas eu de
laissez-passer pour sortir d'ici et nous
ne sommes pas autorisés à rentrer dans
le camp l'italie cherche une solution
politique en tenant compte des attaques
de ses voisins européens qu'il accuse de
laxisme
ces familles recueilli 6 par l'évêque de
lecce ne peuvent pas non plus offrir un
voyage vers l'allemagne où il voudrait
aller les voleurs les pirates de
l'adriatique nous ont pris notre argent
et nos bijoux de 17 hommes alors qu'on
était tous sur le bateau oui c'était des
albanais le voyage a été très difficile
ça faisait 3 - qu'on le prépare est dit
aziz et tous sont unanimes pour dire
qu'ils ont payé le prix fort 3000 marque
plus de dix mille francs à des passeurs
corrompus les deux capitaine du bateau
qui avait tenté de se fondre dans la
masse des réfugiés à l'arrivée du navire
ont été arrêtés ce sont eux ils seront
jugés
mais cela n'empêche pas les réfugiés de
demander l'asile à l'europe sur cette
banderole ils ont écrit un accueil digne
mais pas dans des containers et il garde
l'espoir malgré tout comme sammy
l'information disant que plus de dix
mille réfugiés kurdes eux se préparent à
quitter la turquie pour l'italie n'est
pas confirmé ici
mais les renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières de la france de l'allemagne
ou de l'autriche ne devrait guère
découragé de nouveaux candidats à
l'exode
ce soir nous parviennent par la
télévision algérienne les témoignages
des rescapés de la tuerie qui aurait
fait 412 morts la première nuit du
ramadan
le chiffre n'est pas confirmé
officiellement ce nouveau massacre et
bien sûr dénoncé unanimement y compris
et c'est une surprise par l'iran
qui parle d' acte condamnable et
répugnant l'iran que l'algérie accuse de
soutenir les terroristes du gia
jérôme bonnet c'est le premier soir du
ramadan mardi dernier que la vie de
cette jeune rescapée de 15 ans a basculé
dans le cauchemar sont venus la nuit
pour m'égorger à l'hôpital de relizane
dans l'ouest algérien
les rares survivants du massacre le plus
meurtrier depuis le début des violences
il ya six ans ce bébé à tout juste
survécu à l'égorgement sept autres a été
piétinée je suis seul maintenant ils
m'ont frappée à la tête pendant une demi
heure
j'ai été pris de vomissements sur place
quand j'ai repris mes esprits je suis
rentré chez moi pour trouver mes enfants
tous tués ainsi que leur mère tu ne
pouvais pas les approcher il avait
l'aspect diabolique puisqu'une jamais
d'en croiser on murmure ici que le
massacre aurait duré sept heures presque
toute la nuit dans les quatre villages
martyrs
certains des assassins descendus des
montagnes connaissait bien l'endroit
il ya parmi eux des gens du village
il dirigeait l'opération ils ont aidé
ceux qui ont commis ces actes sans eux
les assaillants ne serait jamais arrivé
jusqu'à nous sendphotos l'état nous
avait demandé de nous armer et nous
avions refusé
voilà où tout cela nous a conduits jeu
maintenant nous voulons des armes pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
quelques fusils de chasse qui
n'apporteront pas forcément la sécurité
à ces populations algériennes
le mois du ramadan valeur sembler bien
long et on a appris que 13 autres
personnes avaient été assassinées dans
la nuit de jeudi à vendredi dans la
région du centre de l'algérie
en israël le ministre des affaires
étrangères david levy claque la porte du
gouvernement le plus modéré de l'équipe
netanyahu entend protester contre
l'austérité annoncée du budget et aussi
contre la politique de benjamines de
benyamin nétanyahou vis-à-vis des
palestiniens
david l'évier encore 48 heures pour
faire machine arrière lui qui a souvent
menacé de démissionner semble pourtant
avoir cette fois pris une décision
définitive en israël charles enderlin
même quelqu'un qui a l'expérience de la
politique israélienne comme moi fini par
en avoir marre j'en ai marre visiblement
soulagé d'avoir finalement pris sa
décision
david lévy explique qu'il ne pouvait
plus rester dans un gouvernement qui
viole tous ses engagements sur le front
social et bloque le processus de paix
avec les palestiniens
il a craqué en découvrant que le projet
de budget 81,18 présenté au parlement
comportait de nombreux cadeaux pour les
écoles talmudiques des ultra orthodoxes
et les implantations juives en
cisjordanie et à gaza sans prévoir de
réelle lutte contre le chômage en hausse
sensible en israël benyamin nétanyahou
n'a donc plus qu'une seule voix de
majorité mais bien que sa coalition
parlementaire soit hétérogènes et
instable il n'a pas l'intention de
démissionner le premier ministre l'a
annoncé ce soir en répondant à ces
critiques par une longue déclaration
reprenant les acquis de son gouvernement
seuls at il dit capable de gérer le pays
tous les commentateurs politiques
israéliens estiment que dans ces
conditions
monsieur netanyahou ne pourra pas rester
longtemps au pouvoir
les jours de sa coalition sont comptés
et des élections anticipées par est
inévitable dans les tout prochains mois
en fait la campagne électorale a peut
être commencé ce soir 18 18 mois après
l'envoi de premier colis piégés aux
états unis les américains vont peut-être
savoir si le mystérieux una bombers et
bien cet ancien universitaire arrêté
dans une cabane au milieu de la forêt du
montana où il vivait en ermite
son procès s'ouvre demain à sacramento
en californie philippe gas sous
l'accusation va s'employer à démontrer
que cet homme théodore kazim
qui qui se présente devant la justice de
sacramento et bien yuna bamber que c'est
bien lui il y a dix huit ans qui
envoyait son premier colis piégé suivi
de 15 autres au total trois personnes
ont été tuées et 23 autres blessées
il risque la peine de mort à travers le
washington post contraint de publier son
idéologie anti technologique son frère
reconnaît son argumentaire son style il
le dénoncera aujourd'hui david kazinsky
prétend que les procureurs l'ont trompé
qu'il lui avait promis de ne pas
requérir la peine de mort
il sera témoin numéro un l'accusé ancien
diplômé de mathématiques d'harvard d
professeur à berkeley va voir défiler
les victimes souvent marqués à vie
elles n'ont toujours pas compris le
geste du tueur
quand j'ai ouvert la bombe a explosé mon
bras était soufflé sur le côté comme ça
et la première chose à laquelle j'ai
pensé c'est pourquoi pourquoi ont-ils
fait ça le dossier de l'accusation est
épais les preuves accumulées contre
l'accusé accablante dans la cabane en
planches où il était terré ses écrits ne
laisse pas de doute la machine à écrire
est la même il y à tous les détails
consignait sur les colis piégés envoyés
le mathématicien n'a rien oublié
pas même une bombe prête à exploser on
retrouvera chez lui les lunettes de
soleil et le pull à capuche afin
d'appuyer les jurés quatre hommes et
huit femmes sur les conditions
d'existence du prévenu la cabane du
montana a été transporté jusqu'à
sacramento une façon de lui donner une
toute petite chance
théodore kazinsky n'a pas voulu jouer la
seule carte qui pouvait peut-être lui
sauver la mise
celle de la maladie mentale que lui
proposait ses défenseurs et c'était pas
dix huit 18 mois après le roi des
premiers colis piégés mes 18 ans bien
sûr en france à metz l'un des hommes
soupçonnés d'avoir participé au triple
meurtre du cabaret le palladium la nuit
de la saint sylvestre s'est rendu à la
police
un avis de recherche a été lancé contre
ses deux complices et à besançon c'est
un jeune homme de 20 ans qui a été mis
en examen et écroué il a laissé l'un de
ses chiens pitbulls morts grièvement son
jeune frère de 11 ans à deux reprises en
décembre virgin est fiché et patrick
schumacher
c'est une histoire qui commence et se
termine en drame
depuis quatre ans mohamed 20 ans et ses
trois frères vivait seule dans un
appartement de cette cité orphelin les
quatre garçons avaient perdu leurs
parents dans un accident de la route
avec les adolescents vivait aussi trois
chiens apparenté au pitbull le mois
dernier l'un d'eux a mordu à deux
reprises l'un des frères âgé de 11 ans
l'enfant a dû être hospitalisé dans le
quartier certains habitants sont
aujourd'hui un qui moi personnellement
j'ai deux jeunes enfants
je me sens moins en sécurité quand ils
en changent dans le quartier un chien
peut être à la merci d'être agacé énervé
et donner un peu de temps et puis a
blessé un enfant
en plus de ses propres chiens mohamed
avait recueilli il ya quelques mois un
autre pitbull adultes c'est ce dernier
qui a blessé le petit mehdi ce n'est pas
le même m alors c'est comme ça c'est
pour ça que le cheylard a dit
différemment parce que comme c'est pour
ça qu'il a commencé à mantoue sans les
dresser ce n'est pas lui qui l'a il
l'avait pas au doigt elle y croit parce
que par moments le chien doit être bien
dans sa tête c'est tout mais ce n'était
pas un chien méchant non cet accident
relance néanmoins la polémique autour
des chiens d'attaqué et le parquet de
besançon a décidé de réagir
nous avons effectivement le sentiment
qu'il y à une plus grande présence de
ces chiens dans les quartiers sans
pouvoir toutefois la mesure est très
efficacement du je crois que nous allons
très rapidement nous atteler à ce
problème elle prendre des mesures pour
essayer d'inventorier le nombre de ces
chiens présents dans le quartier
aujourd'hui mohamed et écroué il a été
mis en examen notamment pour mise en
danger d'autrui et blessures
involontaires
le sport maintenant avec d'abord le
football et la victoire sans problème
d'auxerre face à guingamp en match
avancé des 16e de finale de la coupe de
la ligue 3 0 buts de chalier de dives
archers de lachuer pour une fois guy
roux n'était pas sur le banc de touche
il a suivi tout ça tranquillement chez
lui tous les coups jobbik par une
bronchite
le paris dakar avec la première étape
africaine entre nador et errachidia dans
sa catégorie moto c'est le grand favori
cap le vainqueur de l'épreuve le
français stéphane peterhansel qui
l'emportent et prend du même coup la
première place au classement général
christophe duchein hier soir la grande
caravane du paris dakar a quitté la
mairie en espagne d'un continent à
l'autre de l'europe à l'afrique au tout
petit matin le petit monde du rallye
arrêté au maroc à nador d'une certaine
manière c'est là le vrai départ d'une
course où contrairement aux chèvres et
moutons on ne se déplace pas en troupeau
ici c'est chacun pour sa peau chacun sa
vitesse son sens de l'orientation
ça ne surprendra personne pas même les
chèvres marocaine le plus rapide lors
des 2 147 km de spéciale a été stéphane
peterhansel déjà quintuple vainqueur
chez les motards
il a pris aujourd'hui la tête du
classement général et pourtant ça n'a
pas été de tout repos
très piégeux et donc la grosse
difficulté c'est surtout ne pas tomber
pour moi je suis tombé encore une fois
hier il faut aujourd'hui sans gravité la
moto encore en prit quelques petits eu
quelques petits bobos pour éviter les
bobos il ne faut pas confondre vitesse
et précipitation
une voiture à fond les gamelles une moto
à fond les manettes bref tout le monde
d'un fond les ballons et ce sans limite
sous vichy qui aurait nié sans partage
aujourd'hui sur l'état victoire pour le
209 japonais hiroshi masuoka 4
mitsubishi aux quatre premières places
et toujours le maillot jaune de leader
au classement général pour le français
bruno saby de sape de sens 1
aujourd'hui certains sont restés dans la
semoule
mais heureusement sans gravité ce soir
les concurrents sont arrivés à
errachidia au maroc venu il doit y avoir
couscous voilà une bonne surprise dans
la coupe du monde de ski avec la
deuxième place du français pierre
bourgeois tu vois ici dans le slalom de
kranjska gora en slovénie
l'épreuve a été remportée par thomas
sykora il faut dire que la neige était
en très mauvaise de très mauvaise
qualité dans les hautes-alpes seul c'est
chasser le sachet le une avalanche a
emporté six skieurs qui était hors piste
trois d'entre eux sont blessés mais
trois autres ont été tués
même si cela revient sur la scène il
sera au zénith à paris les 9 et 10
janvier avant d'entamer une tournée en
province
alors avant de recevoir celui que l'on
présente souvent comme un poète du rap
est un magicien des mots son portrait
avec pascal des champs elysées dahan
qu'ils l'ont filmé à los angelès 1994
pour son premier mythe mc solaar fait un
tabac le grand public qui s'est
précipité sur ses deux premiers albums
découvre un époustouflant spectacle de
deux heures entouré de sa bande de
villeneuve saint georges
cet amoureux des mots se révèle aussi un
formidable show man
quatre ans plus tard ce jour d'octobre
température extérieure 28 degrés c'est
dans l'exiguïté d'un studio de los
angeles qu'il se prépare des loops
savoir d'où des boucles du son avec
voilà du sang synthétique et après il va
encore le doublé pour mettre une super
puissance avec le passé nous revient
comme un bilboquet la présence d'un pass
est omniprésent n'est pas passé mehal
supplanté par le cos allégorie des
madeleines file à la vitesse de postes
et là on s'est donné deux dimensions une
dimension live et et puis aussi des fois
changer un peu les morceaux alors voici
ici qu'on a décidé de le faire parce que
on est à l'écart de paris on est forcé
de de ne pas sortir de palais à droite à
gauche
et puis deux parce que les gens qui le
font sont des gens de qualité
si m6 picot s'il english sait-on
français qu'il s'est fait ici une
réputation surprise pour les dizaines de
musiciens auditionnés ils étaient loin
d'être un inconnu grâce à une radio de
los angeles qui le programme depuis cinq
ans cela fait des années que je suis un
truffade parce qu'il ya chez lui à la
fois une énergie et une force lyrique
je ne parle pas de mots mais de la
musique qui le rendent unique à mes yeux
je ne connais rien de ce genre aux états
unis pour moi c'est tout à fait nouveau
preuve frêche
désormais je passe à la télé on me
connaît les rapports sont français l'ère
moderne au moyen âge
je garde le qi sa vie cela bonsoir donc
vous pas sa lettre à la télé les
rapports sont fausses et ils sont
vraiment faussé fossé c'est difficile de
rester en contact avec la vie réelle
quand on devient une star que vous
l'êtes maintenant c'est difficile quand
conflits tourné parce qu'on a toujours
le côté positif du des spectateurs des
gens qui sont venus pour faire la fête
et et qu'on a envie d'être une sorte de
deux chroniqueurs c'est vrai qu'il faut
aussi retourner dans dans les ruelles
dans les rues et sur les boulevards les
avenues pour voir un peu ce qui se passe
dans la vie de tous les jours ils
pouvaient le faire encore tout à fait
naturellement son corps on soude sans
être assailli par vaux vos fans
oui c'est bien sûr ils sont assez ils
sont assez respectueux c'est le moment
où ils prennent un peu de d'énergie de
speed et 2,8 deviennent d'aider des
fanatics et c'est aux alentours des
concerts donc à ce moment là mais bon
elle accepte aisément vous préférez quoi
les périodes des concerts qui sont n'ai
pas de contacts 7 d'enregistrement ou de
recherche d'écriture vous êtes peut-être
plus seule la période d'écriture c'est
bien parce qu'on est on est on a envie
de lancer une unité interne
quelquefois polémique mais le meilleur
moment je parle pour la joie personnelle
et pour la joie qu'on peut donner c'est
effectivement le concert on arrive dans
des salles qui sont bouillonnante on a
des gens de toutes générations qui se
retrouve à un même endroit pour la même
chose et puis nous on a aussi une envie
de les satisfaire
je crois que c'est le meilleur moment
parce que c'est immédiat autant il est
pas très très souvent parce que ça fait
trois ans qu'on vous a pas eu sur cette
suis bien compris oui ça fait trois ans
que c'est que j'ai pas fait de scène ça
nous a manqué énormément nos retours de
paris à paris chez nous je parle de
toute l'équipe en était une quinzaine de
personnes a trouvé ça un peu
olala ça nous manque c'est fade et là on
ne repart avec un optimiste pour voir
les quatre coins où les six coins de
l'hexagone orties qu'heureux
horticulteurs des mots au magicien poète
du rap son expression qu'on emploie
beaucoup pour vous sont des expressions
qui vous qui vous plaisent qui vous
satisfont et j'aime bien être en rupture
par rapport à l'image classique qu'on a
du rappeur à savoir quelqu'un d'arrogant
de speed direct et de pas réfléchi au
moins si on fait un travail sur
l'écriture d'un côté surnom une envie de
communication et de donner du plaisir
plutôt que donner de la grisaille ça me
fait plaisir alors horticulteurs des
mots c'est vrai j'aime jouer avec les
mots les triturer dans tous les sens et
je l'assumé fort bien ça vient d'où
cette passion on dit vous étiez enfin
vous êtes un fan de dictionnaires pas
s'il ya des après midi entiers abogo
quand on était jeunes on a encore plus
jeune que maintenant il ya les deux
aspects al côté de de la rue en bas de
la tour c'est à dire qu'on parle entre
entre entre amis et puis la découverte
des des bouquins des dictionnaires des
journaux par beaubourg vous êtes un
dévoreur je suis un rat de bibliothèque
au monde où un dévoreur j'aime savoir
tout ce qui se passe et vous imprégner
de quoi aussi l'actualité ce qui fait de
ce dont on parle dans la rue vous dites
mais aussi dans l actualité à la
télévision etc
l'actualité la télévision tout ce qui se
passe j'essaye de trouver une espèce de
comment on appelle ça en mathématiques
le plus petit dénominateur commun vous
bien le plus grand dénominateur commun
c'est à dire pouvoir exprimer des idées
mais en servant de tout ce qui tout ce
qu'on connaît alors il ya la pub des
formules courtes les slogans des
paradoxes tout ce que vous faites tout
ce qui tourne autour des mots et de la
rhétorique m'intéresse c'est bon on
entend beaucoup de formules de slogans
de marque dans vos dans vos chansons ce
parce que la pression ça fait partie du
quotidien de tout le monde et que ça
doit exister dans la poésie
oui je pense que si on veut faire de la
poésie urbaine et moderne
il faut se servir de de même si c'est un
petit mâle savoir qu'on est supra
conditionné mais c'est dans la vie de
tous les jours alors pour toucher que
certaines personnes bien sûr quelquefois
il faut des marques que je ne citerai
pas soi alors quand on vend quand on
parle de vous comme un rappeur gentil si
on veut caricaturé par rapport à des
groupes qui serait plus violents ça vous
plaît ou ça vous plaît ça me plaît
énormément
bien avoir un espèce de flou en espèces
de ce style qui est la représentation du
rap
après si on veut me présenter comme un
gars mes chances par mon but
chez moi nous vend ses quads et autres
groupes qui sont beaucoup plus agressifs
ben si ils ont un sujet je crois que le
style importe peu c'est le sujet si
c'est un sujet qui est valable que si
son agressif quand il parle de de deux
choses qui vont mal dans le social là
c'est une raison d'être agressif
sinon celui-ci de la provocation
gratuite je trouve que c'est pas pour
moi en tout cas
mais pourtant failli parle souvent de la
banlieue il parle de la jeunesse
vous l'avez connu aussi vous étiez vous
êtes originaire de banlieue aussi vous
en parlez aussi dans vos chansons mais
pas de la même façon
non je ne parle pas de la même façon
parce que le simple fait de pouvoir
parler c'est qu'il ya déjà eu un
cheminement qui a été fait j'espérais
toujours un représentant de quelqu'un
venu de la périphérie
et puis ensuite je pense qu'il faut
faire des prendre du recul en tout cas
pour ma part il ya souvent les soldats
et puis ce qui est d'abord les plans
jamais depuis qu'elle abhorre le plan ce
qui est un peu après au dessus de la
mêlée qui est pas non pas d'en bas dans
l'arrogance sait trop comment dire c'est
trop formaté l'arrogance et j'aime la
poésie et je pense que je parle pas
simplement à des gens qui sont versées
qui souhaite quelque chose de dur mais
mais c'est quelque chose d'ouverture
quand j'essaie d'être ouverts ne
m'intéressait aussi bien aux fans à drap
qu'à mes amis de clarisse raté sculpter
sa différence à tout petit mot encore du
cinéma par exemple chose qui pourra vous
tenter un jour vous dites de voir ma
tête à la fiche du cinéma ça vous fait
peur que ça fait peur des bulles quoi ça
me faisait peur parce que moi j'avais
l'habitude de voir ma petite tête sur un
petit disque effectués
c'est peut-être un jour quand je suis
réjouis merci beaucoup de cadavres c'est
une autre invitation aujourd'hui si
l'aéronaute américain steve fossett à
quelques difficultés au dessus de la
république tchèque et de la roumanie
partie le 31 décembre de saint louis
dans le missouri
il a bien débuté son tour du monde en
ballon mais les vents maintenant lui
sont moins favorables patrice pollet
steve fossett et son ballon viennent de
quitter le ciel de bulgarie pour fin
d'après midi
il est rentré en contact avec la tour de
contrôle j'espère pouvoir rattraper les
jet stream les courants d'altitude pour
partir vers le sud de l'europe
et si ce n'est pas possible je prendrai
la direction de la russie
steve fossett dans son ballon véritable
usine est parti mercredi de saint louis
dans le missouri
il tente de réaliser une première le
tour du monde en ballon sans se poser
parti de rien aujourd'hui milliardaire
son opiniâtreté l'a déjà conduite deux
fois dans les airs
deux tentatives deux échecs mais il
reste confiant voilà ce qu'il déclarait
hier envol avec ce ballon j'espère
pouvoir attraper les meilleurs courants
et surtout que cette fois ci j'aurai
plus de chance que l'année dernière
l'esti fawcett a pensé à tout sa
tentative est relatée chaque seconde sur
internet
ici on peut tous avoir comme par exemple
que son ballon est formé de deux
enveloppes une poche d'hélium et une
autre de gaz chaud cette dernière assure
la montée et la descente fawcett est
loin d'avoir bouclé son périple le
survol de l'ukraine de la chine de
l'océan pacifique l'attendent un tour du
monde qu'il espère boucler non pas en 80
jours comme dans le roman de jules verne
mais en moins de trois semaines 18 jours
je rappelle les principaux titres de ce
journal la tempête souffle sur tout
l'ouest de la france des vents de 180
km/heure des creux de plus de 10 mètres
mais heureusement pas trop de dégâts
pour l'instant
la crise en israël avec la démission du
ministre des affaires étrangères david
levy l'ennemi intime de benyamin
nétanyahou dispose encore de 48 heures
pour faire machine arrière
le paris dakar première étape africaine
et d'entrée de jeu le grand favori dans
la catégorie moto le français
peterhansel se portent à la première
place alors un instant la météo d'isabel
martinez qui vous parleront encore
devant à 13 heures ce sera bien sûr
laurence piquet patrick chêne demain à
20h vous retrouverez daniel bilalian et
tout de suite à 20h50 votre film
dimanche soir masque d'or avec jean reno
bonne soirée sur france 2
les marques